tonight
Oscar Pistorius makes an emotional
apology as he gives evidence in his own
defense for the very first time in his
murder trial I can't imagine the pain
intimacy love caused you the athlete
tells the family of his girlfriend reeva
Steenkamp that he was only trying to
protect her on the night that he shot
her dead when she wins bid that night
she felt loved
good evening from the High Court in
Pretoria where after five weeks of
waiting the world finally heard from
Oscar Pistorius himself the olympian
began his defense with the tearful
address to the family and friends of his
girlfriend reeva Steenkamp the athlete
said that his girlfriend had gone to bed
on the night that he shot her feeling
loved and he insisted that despite what
happened that night he'd only been
trying to protect her Lisa Holland now
reports on a compelling day in court
thank you my lady for mr. Pistorius for
15 days Oscar Pistorius sat in the same
courtroom seat he wept
he listened now he would take the stand
to defend himself first walking past his
own relatives then the family of the
woman he killed even past the door he
fired through delivering those fatal
shots
say please the different names of the
river my name is Oscar Leonard called
Pistorius do you have any objection in
taking the prescribed dose m'lady you
consider the probable to be binding on
the conscience 19 milady
do you say about it everything's about
to give shall be the truth old your sole
reason I gonna see some people hope you
good Oscar Pistorius agreed his evidence
would be heard but not seen
he began his defence with an apology
directly addressing Reavers family
including her mother who remained
impassive I would like to take this
opportunity to apologize to
this isn't missus instant to leave his
family to those of you yet today mr.
krinsman
I don't like doing this to you but I can
hardly hear I'm already all speak up
I'd like to apologize and say that these
a lot of moments and there hasn't been a
moment since since this tragedy happened
that I haven't thoughts about your
family I wake up every morning the first
people I think of the first people are
praying for I can't imagine the pain and
the sorrow and the intimacy love close
to you your family I was simply trying
to protect you God I can promise that
when she went to bed that night she felt
loved I've tried to put my words on
paper many many times to you the Olympic
athlete said he had taken sleeping
tablets and antidepressants since the
death of his girlfriend reeva Steenkamp
mr. Pistorius are your medication
medication since last year
about the third week of February I've
changed my medication over the course of
the last over the course of the last 14
months but what medication here you
I would suppose it's on an
anti-depressive called Super Bowl and in
the beginning of last year I started
taking a sleeping sedated called called
Norma's in and later on I got my
medicine change to a medicine called
super Alex and doorman rocked and Molly
Paxson m'lady did you have a difficulty
in sleeping I do my lady
um
I'm scared to sleep
for several reasons but I have I have
terrible nightmares buts about things
that happen at nights when I wake up in
us well this well good small blood and I
wake up to being terrified for noise I
wake up just in a complete state of
terror it's a point that I'd rather not
sleep then can fall asleep and wake up
like that so for many weeks I I didn't
sleep a night in March April last year
lustre significant amounts of weight and
I sought medical advice to young to
start medication for steeping Oscar
pistorius's sister fought her own
emotions as she listened to her brother
described how on one occasion he was so
disturbed he climbed into a cupboard
then called her I woke up in a panic you
know
I'm blistered my sister stays on the
same property as I do so I can phone her
in the middle of the night which I often
do it's coming so Bobby and on that
particular night I don't obviously ever
want to handle a firearm again we'll be
around farm so I've got a security guard
that stands outside of my friend Ward
nut but I woke up and I was terrified
of some reason couldn't calm myself down
so I come into the cupboard enough find
my sister to come and sit but she did
oscar pistorius set out a picture of a
determined man who against the odds
became one of the world's best known
athletes his legs were amputated when he
was just 11 months old his parents
divorced and he lost his mother when he
was 15 mother was very supportive she I
remember when my brother went to school
she said to me that she wasn't gonna
she's a bit carefree she said she wasn't
going to do trip so I must find a sport
to do and she never made me feel any
difference to the rest of the kids she
she didn't even want me to see my
disability as it's something that should
hold me back he told the court he grew
up in a household fearful of crime my
mother had a lot of security concerns we
obviously grew up in a family where my
father wasn't around much so my mother
she she had a pistol and she would often
get scared at night and she would find
find the police we didn't stay in the
best of suburbs and he was often crime
in the area on a couple of occasions I
did break into our home but more than
often they're not so it was just her
being scared so she'd come you know if
not some call us to go sit in their room
and many times we just wait for the for
the police to arrive she kept her farm
you know you know you know you know
padded bag under her pillow he told the
court about the impact of losing his
legs if you're on your stunts
what is your balance like I don't have
balance or Muslims I can stand on my
steps I can't stand still on my stamps I
put my prosthetic legs next to my bed
when I wake up in the morning I put them
on and when I go to bed at night I take
them off so I sold them don't I saw them
have time when I not wearing my
prosthetic legs on the odd occasion I'd
farm in my room I wouldn't put them on
if I just wanted to stretch or if I
wanted to fish something in a crisis of
close proximity but I don't have very
good balance I think it's just as a temp
UT it's not an uncommon thing it's
prosthetic limb or a wheelchair in many
disabled people it's an extension of
your body I wouldn't leave my prosthetic
legs lying around
Oscar Pistorius told the court how a
boating accident in 2009 had left him
withdrawn I could only see the Sun on
the water and cover seconds later I just
remember the sound of the propeller in
the boats I hit the steering wheel and
propeller went into the air I remember
the sound of the engine and then when I
work at Firefox it was just hot it was
very warm in the boats
it was very dark where we were it was I
remember my face was very hot and at
that point I realized that most of my
face had been smashed in from my nose
down there is a massive impact my lady
I think I was just a lot more vigilant
of losing my life after that I became a
bit fearful I became quite withdrawn
remember reading in the media that I've
been drinking at the time of the
accident and people were joking about it
and saying you know I was drunk and
listen this but didn't understand that I
nearly lost my life
welcome back to Pretoria where Oscar
pistorius's started giving evidence in
his defense and earlier he told the
court about his South African upbringing
and how he had become one of the world's
most famous athletes and during this
afternoon's testimony his lawyer Barry
Roux asked him about his experiences
with alcohol and drugs in the month
month and a half that I that I had to
break I would drink sometimes
excessively I mean we do use drugs when
my mother passed away when I was fifteen
I smoked I smoked - her with a friend
and besides on the occasion I haven't I
haven't consumed or taken more I haven't
taken any substances since then I've
never taken any sports enhancing drugs
or anything that would give me a
advantage over my competitors ever been
and I want you to think back over the
span of your lifetime being exposed to
crime I think everybody in South Africa
has been exposed to crime at some point
so I think when I grew up we were
exposed to cry we had many hast
break-ins when I was growing up we had
one at my father's home in Johannesburg
when we were on holiday when we got back
to the house
they'd ransacked the entire house and
that one of the intruders or burglars
had cut his hand I think and he'd wax
the blood all over the wall and they had
pulled the safe out of the house using a
motor vehicle and then living with my
mother we were broken into him on
several occasions and they stole small
items we didn't have much so they saw TV
sets and VCRs and things like that
my father has been hijacked twice my
brother wasn't an attempted hijacking
many members of my family have been
victims of past break-ins and violent
crime have you ever been a victim to cry
yes I have
my home had been broken into in 2005 TV
had been stolen and a laptop and my
car's roof had been cut in that same
home one night there was somebody in my
garden they kicked I had a Jack Russell
they kicked the Jack Russell that had
needed to go to the vet and get medical
treatment I've been followed home late
at night I've been shot at on the
highway the one occasion I was driving
back from interview in Johannesburg and
a car came up behind me like was going a
lot faster than I was and I changed
lanes that came past me and it slowed
down a couple of car lengths in front of
me and I just saw a muzzle flash it was
dark and I saw the muzzle flash and
could hear the bang from coming from the
vehicle I was followed home one night
there were two occupants in the vehicle
I phoned the security gates at the
estate that I stayed at from the
entrance of our state or sped up I
jumped out of the car and I distance
myself from the car and I had my firearm
by my side I didn't draw it but I had my
hand on it on my hip and two gentlemen
in the car sped off
they've been other occasions with
similar cars with the same looking car
has followed me for a couple of days at
a time and I wasn't sure of who it was
or what it was but I found my agents and
informed him have you ever it's just
that someone is a victim
right these two men were pulling the
woman around and I got off the car and I
I told them to back up and leave her and
I waited there was a police patrolling
car in the area and somebody of our
stand I called the policeman generally
about two kilometers from my home us
coming back from a training session mid
one morning with two occupants and the
driver got off the taxi and they started
smashing the windscreen and the window
the driver's window of this taxi they
smashed the window and they dragged the
guy asked him to the streets they
started beating him with rocks and ease
in his face and in his age at that point
I jumped the Rope I had jumped the light
hooted until I pulled up I drew my
firearm pointed it at the three people
they jumped in the taxi they sped off
and then in December 2012 I was
assaulted at a get-together
since I got hits in the head and I ended
up later that day receiving stitches and
in the back of my head and I had a look
two days later I reported the incident
it's a matter of interest sense that the
fateful day have you ever been back to
the estate haven't been back milady
and do you know of any crime in that
mistake
mr. Mandela area I was aware that he had
been a victim of crime in our estates
whereby the only state security had used
a letter to gain access to the second
floor of his home during the day on the
way after was the open garage and they
went in and they tired the housekeeper -
they stole artists of the interest and
then they were one of two hast breakings
where we had increased the security of
the estate the homeowners association
my relationship with Riva
I was kind of taken aback by her and
just bowled over by our much office I
thought about buying a house in Joburg
and I had been for some time I went to
look at her house in in in in Jonas burg
in December 2012 and I liked it and I
placed
but an offer to purchase the house which
was accepted your allegiance that
important to you yeah my religion is
very important to me my mother sang in
the choir on Sundays at the church
my mother told me that you know we've
got just knowing that religions gods
you know our refuge and doesn't matter
what may come of laughs which you can
always turn to the Lord when my mom
passed away I struggled a bit with my
faith but I always knew that the Lord
was part of my laughs 2011-2012 my
religion really started that I put a lot
of faith in the Lord to get where I
wanted to be and then when I met Riva I
think it was just a blessing I've always
wanted to have a partner that was a
Christian she was a she was a very
strong Christian she she would pray for
me at night she would pray about
everything
prayer baths my training prayer baths
all the small things I had in my life
you know we'd pray before we eat and
yeah I mean think the religions maybe
would it definitely is God's the thing
that's got through me through this last
year I mean if in times that I've just
been
just struggling you're nuts
my cards but My gods my god of refuge
slow did you sleep last night
no sir
I'm the weight of this is extremely
overbearing I think it's just a lot to
think about what to discuss this
dramatic first day of the defense
evidence in court here today our special
correspondent Alex Crawford and Martin
hood who's a criminal lawyer here in
South Africa figured see both Alex we've
waited over a month for the defense to
stop and to see Oscar on the stand and
it was a pretty dramatic start I mean
we've already seen him vomiting in court
we've already seen him crying copiously
when he was at his bail application
hearing he simply couldn't control
himself so I don't think there was many
people who didn't expect him to cry when
he was giving evidence and it began
within moments I mean within moments of
arriving at the witness box he wanted to
address a June Steenkamp his
girlfriend's mother and make this very
quiting tearful apology to them and as
he talked through his childhood through
all the disadvantages he had losing his
mother at an early age all the
difficulties and and the pain of what he
was going through his whole family were
crying Steenkamp was on the other hand
were were very different they were very
stoic and June Steenkamp in particularly
even when he was very tearfully
addressing her just stared straight
ahead and once the cameras were switched
off at the end of the day Oscar
literally collapsed on the on the desk
his siblings and all his family rushed
to him and again then he sat down on the
floor of the witness stand box and again
sobbed with the psychologist having to
stroke his his face and trying to get
him to compose himself so very
emotionally draining for all concerned
today a Martin when you see such emotion
and the fact they had to call it quits
forty minutes in the afternoon session
because Pistorius is so exhausted it
doesn't bode well for the next few days
ahead when he's in that stand because um
he ain't seen nothing yet is he those
are my very words it doesn't bode well
because he's going to go through an
intense cross-examination
some point and that is going to be the
linchpin of this entire process he has
to be able to convince the judge sitting
up there in the Assessors that I'm
telling the truth what I thought and
felt at the time is indeed true and to
be so emotional to be so weak for want
of a better word when you're actually
just giving evidence in your own case
without being under the pressure of
cross-examination doesn't bode well for
what is going to come score but thank
you both very much indeed well the next
compelling episode starts at 9:30 local
time in this courtroom tomorrow morning
8:30 London time and if you miss it like
tonight you can catch up with our
special program at 9:30 every weekday
evening on the Oscar Pistorius murder
trial